we're going to begin though with
troubling developments a new development
actually in the investigation into how
police handled the evaldi school
shooting accounts of what happened that
day have been shifting drastically since
it happened and now cbs news has learned
that pete arendando chief of police for
uvalde schools has stopped responding to
state investigators who had been seeking
another interview with him even as he
was sworn in yesterday to serve on
uvalde city council we've also reached
out to aaron dondo and have not heard
back and we're also learning about new
questions in the account of how the
gunman was able to get into the school
in the first place lily luciano is in
yuvaldi for us where she's been since
the shooting happened and where families
are beginning to hold funerals for those
killed lilia good morning good morning
another day begins here when parents and
families will need that superhuman
strength to walk away from a cemetery
without their children and on top of
that mountain of grief stands a
community that still has more questions
than clarity
a slow somber procession
many dressed in amory joe garza's
favorite color purple
watched as the little girl's casket was
carried into the sacred heart catholic
church in uvalde a texas family run
business donated 19 caskets all
customized to what the children liked
as the wreaths and flowers pile on so do
the questions of a grieving community
starved for answers including how did
the shooter get into the school
authorities initially said the shooter
walked in through a side door left
propped open by a teacher the same
teacher walks back to the exit door
and door remains propped open but that
teacher's lawyer now says she shut it
when she learned there was a gunman on
tuesday dps said that was true the door
was closed but did not lock when shut
like it was designed to but among the
loudest questions is why did it take 75
minutes for law enforcement to confront
the killer this is a parent's nightmare
as her funeral nears this sunday
ten-year-old alithea ramirez's parents
are left with haunting doubts of what
could have been done differently i don't
understand how
police officers you know they're sworn
to protect
and
they're outside the room
and just hearing gunshots
kids screaming
go in there save those kids
the largest police union in texas has
urged all of its members to cooperate
with the authorities investigating the
shooting today is a funeral for jose
flores you might remember we talked to
his family last week his little sister
who survived the shooting had told us he
wanted to be a cop and it's also tony
you will remember this the funeral for
irma garcia the teacher and her husband
joe who died of what family called a
heart attack after she died in the
shooting
a heartbreak rather
yeah just one of the more tragic details
in a very tragic ongoing situation there
in uvalde and the morning continues lily
thank you very much